The equation for our circle is x squared plus y squared equals 2500. Now that's
amazing if you got this equation right. This one wasn't easy. Now, we know this
horizontal distance is x units. That's the distance between these two points,
at least just the horizontal distance. And we know that this vertical distance
is a distance of y units. We started at 0 and we went down y. So, notice that
we've created a right triangle. So we can relate these distances with this side
length. The string is 50 centimeters in length, so we know that x squared plus
y squared equals 50 squared, or 2500. So, no matter where the position of the
string is, this distance relationship will always be true. X squared plus y
squared will always equal 2,500. And it turns out that this distance from the
center to any point on the circle is called the radius. In this case 50
centimeters.